What's my advice to young men seeking a
woman for marriage and family?
Yeah.
Well,
okay,
fine.
That's the same question.
Second question.
That's,
that's pretty straightforward man.
I mean,
you can't eliminate the necessity of
being attracted to one another.
That's important.
And that's mysterious,
you know?
Um,
so for example,
here's a funny thing,
if you,
one of the things we know that attracts
people to one another is bilateral
symmetry.
And so if you take men and you ranked
them by the symmetry of their faces and
then you give the asymmetrical men tee
shirts to wear clean t shirts for a day
and the symmetrical men clean t shirts
to wear for a day.
And then you give the t shirts to women
and you have them rate the,
the odor,
the women rate the odor of the
symmetrical men as more attractive than
the odor of the asymmetrical man.
And then there were other factors that
determined sexual attractiveness that
are based on biological factors that are
so that deeply embedded in terms of
smell,
for example.
So a women also tend to,
uh,
not be sexually attracted to the,
to the scent of men whose,
who have,
if I remember correctly,
it's rh factors that would make for
potential trouble in childbirth.
And the often the reason that the women
give for not preferring the scent of
those men is that they smell too much
like their brother,
something like that.
So there was weird,
mysterious things that determine whether
or not people are sexually and
physically attracted to each other.
And I think it's very important that
that's part of a marital relationship.
The next most important thing is trust.
Man.
It's like there,
there's no marriage that's successful
without trust you guys.
You got to tell each other the truth.
And one of the reasons that you'll
believe that marriage as a,
an oath and uh,
Carl Jung as a bond was necessary.
It's really wise.
It's like,
you know,
telling the truth to someone is no
simple thing because there's a bunch of
things about all of us that are terrible
and weak and reprehensible and shameful
and all of those things.
And they kind of have to be brought out
into the open and dealt with and you're
not going to tell the truth about
yourself to someone who can run away
screaming when you reveal who you are.
And so the marriage bond is something
like,
okay,
here's the deal,
I'm going to handcuff myself to you and
you're going to handcuff yourself to me,
and then we're going to tell each other
the truth and neither of us are going to
get to run away.
And so our,
once we know the truth,
then we're either going to live together
in mutual tournament or we're going to
try to deal with that truth and
straighten ourselves out and straighten
ourselves out jointly.
And that's gonna make us more powerful
and more resilient and more and deeper
and wiser as we progress together
through life.
And,
and I think that's absolutely brilliant
because if you leave the backdoor open,
man,
you're going to use it.
That's for sure.
And the oath is there.
And this was [inaudible] commentary on
the spiritualization of,
of the human pair and by Christian
marriage,
for example,
which emphasized,
uh,
the,
what would you call it,
the subordination of both members of the
marital union to a higher order,
a personality that was embodied in the
figure of the logos.
So the idea is that in,
in,
in the Christian marriage,
for example,
the man isn't the boss and the woman
isn't the boss.
The boss is the mutual personality
composed by the seeking of truth in both
of them.
And that's conceptualized as their,
their joint subjugation to the logos.
And that is absolutely dead on man.
It's like the ruler of your marital life
should be your vow to tell each other
the truth because like in hard times
during your life,
when you've done something stupid and
idiotic might take you down and you
don't have anybody that you can turn to.
You know,
if you have a partner that you can
trust,
you can go say,
hey,
you know,
I made a big financial mistake man.
And it's really torturing me and I feel
like a complete idiot.
And it's really dangerous and the person
there,
it's going to help you figure out what
to do about it and they're going to know
that when they make a stupid mistake and
they're bloody well going to,
that they can come and talk to you and
that you guys are going to work your way
through it and that's a big deal and
there's a couple of things our culture
gets really wrong and one is it devalues
marriage.
That's really a very bad idea because
marriages,
marriages like a third of your life and
maybe more and kids are a third of your
life and your,
your,
your life outside of marriage and kids
is a third of your life.
You know,
approximately speaking and to miss any
of that is a massive,
massive mistake.
Now,
having said that,
I will also say that for some people,
missing one or more of those is
necessary because they have a reason.
Maybe they're brilliantly creative
artists and they need to devote
themselves entirely to their career or
they're outstanding in some way and so
they need.
They can justify the sacrifice of one
part of that tryout of being to another
part,
but for,
but generally speaking,
it's a very dangerous thing and it,
it,
it shouldn't be done.
And also kids get an absolutely terrible
rap,
you know,
because kids are delightful.
If they're well behaved.
One of the chapters in my new book is
called don't let your children do
anything that makes you dislike them and
you can do that,
especially if you discuss it thoroughly
with your spouse.
You're the person that's helping you
discipline the kids and children are the
best company because they're really
enthusiastic about everything.
They love doing new things.
They really love you.
So they're happy that you're around.
Um,
all you have to do is make sure they're
not too hot and they're not too cold and
they've had something to eat and they're
not too tired and you don't expect them
to stay engaged in something for longer
than they can manage because we used to
take our kids when they were little out
to for example,
and they could sit there no problem and
behave really nicely when they were two
and three.
But they couldn't do it for more than
about 45 minutes.
He can't push your luck.
But I also noticed with little kids is
that they got antsy and unreasonable
about five to 10 minutes before the
adults did too.
It's just the adults were too stupid to
notice.
The kids would notice right away.
So,
um,
so back to marriage,
when you look for someone that you're
attracted to,
that you love,
and then you look for someone that you
can bloody well,
trust,
and then you tell them the truth and,
and that way maybe you can get through
life and you can have someone to weave
the rope of your being with and together
to make,
to make your joint ropes stronger and
you can have some continuity in your
narrative and you can have children and
then you can have grandchildren and like
you can have a life man and there's
nothing.
You're so fortunate if you can manage
that.
And so.
Okay.
So there's that one.
So what's my advice to young men seeking
a woman for marriage and family?
Yeah.
Well,
and also,
you know,
marry someone you think would be a good
mother and that has enough sense
generally speaking,
to know that she wants children.
Now,
some women don't want children and fair
enough and some women perhaps shouldn't
have children.
That's also possible,
but the general rule of thumb is
especially once a woman in her mid
twenties,
if she doesn't know that she wants
children or wounded admitted,
unless she has a viciously important
reason,
then she's not oriented properly.
Psychologically she,
she,
she isn't.
She doesn't know what's important in
life.
Now,
that might also be the case with you and
it probably is,
but as a rule of thumb,
that's a really good one.